alter des programms auf meinem
grundstück ja leid in rom ein ganzes
haus weg scheiße raus aus dem
megaprojekt gefängnis
das ist ja immer das enthusiastische
folgen und tests das war richtig gut
[Musik]
ja und man hat schon wieder das flüstern
gehört von mister code kräfte der leider
immer noch probleme hat ne habe ich bin
meinte speck genau meint eck das läuft
nicht so
ist vorbei
ja ich weiß die leute also auch wenn ihr
irgendwelche tipps wisst oder so warum
das bei mm x also
hier dass dort jetzt auch wieder jahre
business geändert habe ich gehe ich hab
das texture pack läuft bei dir genannt
ich klicke jetzt darauf
warten wir meinen kleinen momenten das
dauert ja ein bisschen müsst ihr hier
stand up comedy kurz machen
[Musik]
noch ein bisschen habe ich so sieht das
aus wenn
das einzige was ich sehe ist ein krieger
und karlburg und ich gehe fast direkt
nebendran da
ja warte noch ein bisschen weiter nach
links ja nach vorne nach vorne hierunter
mich
da ja da ist ja ich sehe keine blöcke
da ich stehe auch ein spyder jockey
alter also freue so ist das bei mir das
hat zwar seine vorteile aber es hat auch
seine nachteile
es kann sein und mit kuka denn den neuen
kisten mal an ich habe uns beiden wollte
sehen
wie du
ich habe ich damals denken ja euch
geschenkt bekommen
nein ich wollte ich ein generator oder
sowas schicken schenken wie wäre es wenn
heißt nämlich den namen schenken die
waren hier induction fördern
möchten nehmen einen taktischen fern ist
die schon selber machen ja ich weiß ja
nicht mal wie
internet ja
ja ja
[Gelächter]
also ich finde
ja ich muss
versuchen alter stellt jetzt einfach
nein
wir haben den in der gäste aber
ich kann
mir
das nicht so viel spucke
luft verlieren
so packt einfach über leitern bei mir
kommen jetzt kommt nach oben los war die
jetzt sei auch nicht die
hätte muss sein
[Musik]
das schon irgendwie ärgerlich
was genau
das heißt also der abbau aber ich freue
mich dann ein bisschen kleines
grundstück aus wie neu anfangen bin
gleich wieder da wie hält man im manuel
wieso mir über leitern suchen also
freunde wenn ich lust wegen texte oder
wenn die gute texte quiz der eltern dann
schreibt in die kommentare
es macht keinen sinn schreibt allgemein
seien die kommentare mal schauen ob die
10.000 millionen kommentare knacken
wirtschaftliche wohl 5000 kommentare mit
man kann es ja nachher zu suchen
versucht man hier
sehen das ist grün das lila das ist
solide
ohne gucke einfach mal so warte wie kann
man das machen weil die farbe von durex
kondomen ca
sich so angezeigt wird man kann auch das
zu machen da habe er
bei wasser unten rein tippen
ja ja aber man kann es machen dass das
denn die kisten ein so direkt gefunden
und jetzt jetzt die ganzen internet
hätten
aber
du kannst es wieder richtig was man
denkt etwas wirklich ein hund
das kann sich richtig gut an der
königskette
haben
gesagt dass wir ein bisschen geträumt
alter warum und zwar letztens hat den er
gesagt ihr könnt euch zwar hätten
bereits sich
im juli mit argem einmal mehr nehmen da
habe ich einfach einen stack genommen
wir wollten daraufhin halt auf die
reaktion warten von den leuten weil man
ja weiß das ich je in den anderen augen
bringen genau und jetzt das ist ein paar
tage verstrichen und schlägt einfach die
32 zu viel genommen aber wieder zurück
heftig oder darum gehen dass sie extrem
gegeben also wir haben
ergeben dass das ist halt nur internet
vernetzt das
hat er sich verdient bay zu zeigen wie
schnell so was direkt den lauf macht von
wegen
die haben
[Musik]
ich habe eine petition gemacht und
müssen unterschreiben
wer jedoch besser schreibt einer bei mir
darunter hey leute das geht an euch alle
er wollte dass er unbedingt eine
petition zu 200 daumen runter
die petition welche petition der audi a1
soll
dieses tillich oder ja wir haben locker
damit unter den ersten 50 das
unterschrieben
also da haben sich da haben wir noch
wunderschön schon genug
meinte auch wenn 100 erreicht sind
müssen wir raus
sind
locker milliarden ja so alle nicht mal
so dass diese schäfer wirklich nur 5
millionen stimmen dass er raus kommt das
projekt aber
nicht aber mit alten welt bewegen
und die facebook seite gibt es
facebook fanpage bietet vw käfer oder
ohne scheinst ja die seite also erst war
der hat es erstellt und dann bin ich da
gesehen leiten die seite sind der zweite
liga der erste war wahrscheinlich selber
und dann blockt er uns und dann der
wandel nicht geblockt dann muss man
traurig ist ein bisschen lustig der
dächer witzig aber der ist bestimmt
nicht in der firma naja deswegen ist er
so bieten date das macht keinen spaß
ich mache jetzt war ich so nett bin
nehme ich die arbeit weg und nimm deine
hilfe der wasserrutsche auseinander kann
hier wollen wir das vielleicht einfach
so aufziehen als würde ich einfach mal
wie viel du würdest du es nicht mehr
also macht er einfach so eine ganz
normale folge aufnehmen ich wäre einfach
nicht da und irgendwo zu sehen wie die
sachen verschwinden
was bringt das nicht dann wieder so ein
bisschen hält hat dann wird sie da raus
aus projekt ja okay geht doch raus aus
dem spiel bekommen jetzt nach hause
alter da ist der brocken camps auf
meinem grundstück jetzt mit allerlei
tipps um ein ganzes weg scheiße raus aus
dem megaprojekt gefängnis
das
ist richtig ich habe jetzt schon nicht
mehr gegeben ich weiß ich habe normal so
hinkriege ich hab mir das auf jeden fall
abgekauft
na danke was machst du beim ein
wasserrutsche
nicht gut darunter speed wolltest doch
das kaputtmachen ich habe es geht ja ja
aber was macht beim eine wasserrutsche
robrook ist auch mein grundstück abreise
direkt bitte geh weg
das ist ärgerlich man jetzt bin ich
traurig na gut ich
dass ich mit der spitzhacke schneller
kaputt glas
oder doch wahrscheinlich
einfach nicht so hörst du das bei mir
bei mir ist so ein staubsauger
[Musik]
vom gebäude geburtstag
der staubsauger hörte ihn all dieses
unter gerollt
sie erscheint nicht gut machen so ein
staubsauger
zwischen meinen beinen
aber wir können auch aufnehmen das sehr
produktiv sind als wir sind eigentlich
ganz kontraproduktiver begann alles
abbauen was ich mir die ganze der baut
verbrennen
das habe ich aber sogar gesagt bei der
wasserrutsche das erste projekt wird
sein die wasserrutsche zu bauen und das
zweite projekt ist eine wieder abzubauen
der eine heißt im teamspeak manuel und
der andere heißt caliguri
eigentlich zu verschneiden ja jetzt
versteht gar nichts mehr
kommt es nicht mehr in den firma jetzt
gut aber
ich bin
[Gelächter]
da macht man keine späße wirklich okay
ich bin ein bisschen gay witze sind
einfach richtig geil die ringe regierung
[Gelächter]
karibu gleich treffen uns wieder ich bin
ich gucke so kuckuck wieder hinter jetzt
runter gefallen
ja ich der mal gerne beharrte pimmel
manuel speist gern mit noten
multimarket oder irgendwie so war das
ich konsumiere gerne er cool also ich
der alte und der manuel trifft sich
gerne hätten beide bücher treffen ja nee
da steht das anders ein skype aber jetzt
möchte er
aber
nicht was nicht wahr so was das hat
nichts mehr mit prostituierten zu tun
die cases hinsehen
und jetzt auch das noch viel von mir
nötig wäre das wahrscheinlich zu machen
das ist ein komplett ausfüllen werden
dann hier wohnen werde hier so mehrere
etage einziehen werde naja ich weiß noch
nicht hey
du magst offenbar cote
du magst du bist du ja ich bin ich bin
ich bin der manuell
wer ist jetzt wäre ich will malte
ich bin mal weißt du ja
hier guckt euch jede folge von uns hast
du mal zählt zur um 1 2 ihr seid 30 aber
fogna darf ich eine folge gibt und dann
guckt von dem was ihr tut seit dem 12
aber nicht viel geredet haben wollten
den stimme her seit ihr seid 30 9
555 1000 liegestütze
eintreten dem wasserrutsche ist komplett
weg
das team steckt mir
steine
habe ich halt zwischendurch ist ja auch
eher wie es nicht viele fackeln deine
kollege sehe ich die gesteine aber es
ist schon scheiße aus so ohne irgendwas
worunter her laufen kann ich fühle mich
wohl hier das für eine wasserrutsche
hinbauen oder ach ja einfach so dass wir
vielleicht über den und dann macht mir
das ende einfach lernen
und dann bist du dir dann mit so einem
schlenker und dann machen wir die erst
einen breiten vertun uns dann mache ich
noch mal zwei breit aber dann noch ein
bisschen weil dann brechen wir bei der
hälfte ab
und dann machen wir
ein looping machen dann fällt uns beim
looping machen auf das ist ja gar nicht
geht da ist was er dann herunter fließt
mal mit lover
lover bleibt stabil ja ja ja mit nicht
fließende lava
machen alles kaputt oder einer von touch
schätze
[Musik]
danach wir sind auch so bleibt ich habe
immer ich habe mir zwei dinge achten
julia was ist dieser traum er lebt auf
einem baum
da ist schaut euch leute halt gleich um
gespielt und steht jetzt auch für
bekleidung und auf einem baum
das gab das schreibe ich ihm schild vor
die tür ich hatte
mal klappt es ist
doch mal ne
der stadt chur glaubt der spaß an der
firma ich sehe wirklich schon den finger
jetzt
jemand macht das kann ich mich verlassen
dass ihr nichts passiert ja
was ist simons haus passiert mit den
ganzen cobblestone alter
das alter wird ihr das
kommt mal bitte zu simon manuel hat ganz
viele kleine manuels erschaffen
ja ich kann mir
fahre ich wieder jetzt kommen halte ich
für mitkommen nein jetzt kommen alte
gerade nein das ist mal richtig
ist das schwein
dass das trassee aber was macht die
kommission hier heute ist
man bei wird nicht jetzt denken wir die
leute hey das war boten zooms
dann waren wir das gar nicht
wahr noch firma
ich habe ihn ein schild geschrieben ich
habe geschrieben du bist so ein clown
und legt auf einen baum von conny
wahrscheinlich wieder gleichkommt
er braucht man anfang an so als nicht
mehr gewollt wurde oder so dass ihr
immer in pracht kam dann das beste war
ist noch nicht geweiht liste bahnhof es
gab tiefe löcher waren wir ja
warum nicht also
ich hätte da auch diese stadt erbaut er
war alles hier ja oder wird jetzt
irgendwie
brauche ich weiß noch mal ich habe
bestimmt weiter jetzt irgendwie so
gemacht day
bei gott hab keinen bock das alles
abzubauen ist hier war ich brauche das
nicht raten ab
auch
hier schon mal ein geschenk das ihr
dabei geholfen und grafik dich als haha
nein
ich schenke euch bisschen gold day
rheingold ist zu wertvoll
[Musik]
ich warte nicht du ich bin wieder in
meinem film weil der mann seine filme
ich komme gerade
was ist luxus action concept film
acers
dafür aber ist das nicht eine plattform
wo viele filme sind weil er kein keine
ahnung das bisschen so die einzige wort
die können im drehbuch ist
und zwar geht
dann sollen die jetzt immer nur
jeden geben wir so ein match auch noch
gut geht es nirgendwo mich schlecht weil
[Musik]
es macht spaß sachen kaputt zu machen
was macht ihr das so ich mache sachen
kaputt macht spaß erinnern ich möchte ja
ein bisschen und dann gehts euch so
ein wenn ich das ja es gab
man macht das war ja das ist
atemberaubend was ist so spannend gehört
möchte die hosen dass das paar
so ich denke jetzt folgende sachen diese
an die chance dort habe ich die hierhin
von der firma na ja doch dann steht aber
noch ein halber punkt
doch mal hier jetzt
[Musik]
die sache
so gut
[Musik]
bist du blind date ein munteres auf und
zu er hatte so
sa
von klopp
[Musik]
vor geklaut von ceyoniq den scanner ein
klarer fall ging es
ich bin jetzt hier bei gemeinschaftshaus
so kock crafter ich komme
ich denn jetzt die ganze dings hier weg
dieses ganze geformte krams
man muss darüber springen oder was man
[Musik]
als ob der jackpot
das vergessen
gestreckten dem fest noch kompressor
einfach was ich schenke euch jetzt was
der maler hat den plan was wir haben
wollen
wir schenken den kompressor oder so
das heißt schenkt mir
geschenke nicht
ihre meinung waren dass wenn ihr haben
wollt ja kommen gibt
wartet wenn jetzt ein heftiges crafting
rezept
ja stimmt ja gut jetzt habe ich euch
noch ein halten gegeben
[Musik]
aber ich hab dir die hälfte von meinen
items behalten das weiß ich
hab profi kam mit dem rad geklaut aber
das habe ich gerade eben noch versucht
zu sagen dazu nichts zu sagen ich hab
mir die sachen für den
dingen advance passion blog bei dir
gegönnt als ob
das ist es denn ernst das waren zwei
dinge alter ich brauchte diese
gäste noch zum teil platten ja ich denke
es klappt bei mir von der waldschmidt
die rena ist nicht zu diese
metallplatten meiste gold kabel